[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on vit chaque jour comme le
dernier vous allez chanter les pauvres
bêtes pour moi le film c'est parce qu'on
vient de loin série voilà alors oui
chaque jour comme dernier et vous feriez
pareil c'est seulement ça y est
combien du train train du soir
[Applaudissements]
je me demande vous avez passé des enfin
pas trop aux sirènes de chanter en
anglais vous qui est un peu un citoyen
du monde
vous l'avez pas trop fait vous auriez
pas envie de faire un album en anglais
en fait je les fais d'ailleurs je les
fais et enfin c'est pas mal de justifier
qu'il sorte non justement parce que je
les fais mais très peu de gens savent
que je les ai faits voilà que quelqu'un
sur sur le côté de oued de savoir le
savoir alors c'est très confidentiel
mais voilà je les fais corbeil vous êtes
un citoyen du monde vous chantez en
français n'avait pas cédé à la tentation
de chante en espagnol
cordesse vous faire une petite interview
choix cornélien alors attention vous
avez le choix entre deux choses
après je verrai garder votre voie
actuelle et vendre 100 mille albums ou
vendre dix fois plus de disques mais
chanter comme gilles verdez je garde ma
voix si vous devez avoir un reflex canon
vous choisiriez de faire pipi dès que
vous croisez un poteau dans la rue où
ronnie fait les fesses des gens que vous
croisez
[Rires]
j'ai prédit la prime feriez quoi faire
pipi c'est la preuve c'est pas très
hygiénique mais quand même faire but
vous aurez choisi
gilles verdez et puis aussi oui il aura
à le poteau et rené flamand imaginez
votre nez non là dans les faits main aux
gens tout juge en lui que moi je renifle